[Música]
el gobierno de Venezuela y la oposición
lograron un acuerdo para que dinero
Estatal que está congelado se destina a
gastos humanitarios con la gestión de la
ONU Estados Unidos respondió permitiendo
que la petrolera Chevron vuelva a operar
en suelo venezolano
se suspende el paro Cívico que había en
la ciudad boliviana de Santa Cruz de la
Sierra desde hace 36 días los líderes
accedieron a desbloquear las carreteras
de la región más adinerada debido a que
el congreso Avanza en el debate sobre el
censo poblacional
y Argentina sigue viva en el mundial de
Qatar Francia se convirtió en el primer
equipo en confirmar su paso a octavos de
final las dos elecciones ganaron frente
a México y Dinamarca respectivamente
ampliamos desde nuestros enviados
especiales
Bienvenidos a Franz 24 Estas son las
noticias internacionales del momento y
yo soy María Clara calle y empezamos en
nuestra región América Latina porque en
México el gobierno venezolano y la
oposición firmaron un acuerdo para
volver a las negociaciones y además
dieron un paso inicial recuperar los
activos que tiene el país congelados
internacionalmente para destinar los
gradualmente a gastos humanitarios
cálculos estiman que se podría tratar de
3000 millones de dólares además Estados
Unidos permitirá que la petrolera
Chevron opere de nuevo en suelo
venezolano Luis Muñoz nos amplía
Venezuela está de vuelta gobierno y
oposición firmaron un nuevo acuerdo con
el que buscan recuperar recursos del
Estado bloqueados en el sistema
financiero internacional en el acuerdo
figura cooperación en gastos
humanitarios como el pago de proyectos
de atención médica valorados en más de
2700 millones de dólares y la reparación
de redes eléctricas el presidente
Nicolás Maduro lo celebró en Twitter la
firma del segundo acuerdo parcial entre
el gobierno bolivariano que preside y la
plataforma unitaria de una de las
oposiciones abre paso a un nuevo
capítulo para Venezuela en función de
seguir avanzando hacia la paz y el
bienestar que todas y todos los
venezolanos anhelamos Este es el segundo
acuerdo que llega después de que la mesa
de negociación política fuese suspendida
formalmente en octubre de 2021 sin
embargo Venezuela trata de recuperar
activos perdidos e internacionalmente y
aprovechar su posición en un mercado
energético en crisis esto se demuestra
cuando instantes después del anuncio de
la firma entre gobierno y oposición el
departamento del tesoro de Estados
Unidos informó que autoriza a la
petrolera Chevron a retomar operaciones
limitadas de extracción de recursos
naturales esta acción refleja la
política de larga Data de Estados Unidos
de proporcionar un alivio de sanciones
específico basado en pasos concretos que
alivian el sufrimiento del pueblo
venezolano y apoyan la restauración de
la Democracia
movimientos que confirman que Venezuela
está de vuelta en el tablero político
internacional
Se suspendió el paro indefinido que
había desde hace 36 días en Santa Cruz
de la Sierra en Bolivia los líderes
cívicos levantaron las manifestaciones
luego de que el congreso reactivara un
censo que el presidente Luis Arce había
postergado hasta 2024 la cámara baja Ya
aprobó el proyecto y ahora el senado lo
debate si se aprueba la ley permitiría
que la región más rica de Bolivia tenga
más escaños en el legislativo
tras 36 días levantan la huelga en Santa
Cruz de la sierra la cámara de diputados
boliviana decidió que el censo que había
frenado el presidente Luis Arce se
celebrará el 23 de marzo de 2024
[Música]
también contribuya a la clasificación a
la unidad de nuestro país y ojalá que
hoy
empiecen también a levantarse la medida
de presión que nunca fueron necesarias
la ley fue aprobada por dos tercios de
la cámara baja y fue enviada para su
revisión antes de que sea promulgada por
el presidente Arce el censo el primero
en más de una década permitirá que los
escaños del Congreso sean redistribuidos
antes de las elecciones generales de
la oposición había acusado al gobierno
de querer retrasarlo ya que el
oficialismo podría salir afectado en las
elecciones generales los líderes de
Santa Cruz anunciaron que aún siguen
pendientes de la completa aprobación de
La Ley a partir de este momento
hacemos un cuarto intermedio
levantamos el paro y bloqueos sin
suspender nuestra lucha seguimos en
emergencia en la región más grande de
Bolivia rica en soya la huelga dejó mil
millones de dólares en pérdidas según el
Ministerio de finanzas Mire ya yo andaba
nervioso ansioso medio Bravo medio
triste Pero por fin hoy una buena
noticia que volvemos a la normalidad los
resultados del censo se entregarán en
septiembre por lo que podrán aspirar
nuevos representantes políticos y
obtener asignaciones económicas para la
región y reapareció el presidente
brasileño Ya ir bolsonaro quien no había
salido en público desde el 30 de octubre
cuando se pronunció por perder la
segunda vuelta de electoral frente a
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva bolsonaro
asistió al primer acto público al que ha
ido desde entonces y acudió a una
ceremonia de graduación de Cadetes del
ejército en Resident ubicado en el
estado de Río de Janeiro bolsonaro honró
a los militares recién graduados en la
academia militar de águilas negras donde
el mandatario se graduó en 1977 sin
embargo bolsonaro no rompió su silencio
el desierto de atacama en chile se ha
convertido en un vertedero de basura
Industrial este sitio es ahora un
cementerio de carros viejos y de ropa
nueva o de segunda mano creando un
problema ambiental en esta región del
continente
miles de toneladas de desechos en el
desierto de atacama uno de los más
bellos de América del Sur aquí hay
restos de carrocerías por miles y ropa
más allá de donde alcanza la vista
de hecho Esta es una montaña de ropa
solamente que está tapada con tierra
una camisa de Cualquiera podría terminar
aquí porque estas toneladas de prendas
provienen del mundo entero
hay otras que están en perfecto estado
como este vestido fabricado en India
todo constituye una amenaza para el
medio ambiente según está activista
y ahí no preguntarnos
y acá tienes metidas muchas toneladas de
ropa que son un peligro son un riesgo
ambiental son un peligro para la salud
de las personas ya y no corresponde
estos últimos años el desierto de
atacamas se ha llenado de vertidos no
autorizados
chiles especializa en el comercio de
segunda mano
la mercancía llega hasta aquí a través
del puerto de iquique proveniente de
Europa de Asia o de Estados Unidos antes
de ser llevada al mercado chileno o
exportada a los países vecinos salvo una
parte de la mercancía que se queda en el
desierto de atacama abandonada por los
intermediarios el alcalde de una de las
comunas de la región denuncia a la
pasividad del estado es como el patio
trasero ya ni siquiera somos el patio
trasero local sino que somos parte
trasero del mundo que es peor si no hay
conciencia todavía para poder resolver
este problema por el contrario no
chile recibe cada año unas 59 mil
toneladas de ropa y mucha termina
perjudicando el medio ambiente como en
este caso en el desierto de atacama de
chile pasamos a Qatar porque hay
noticias del mundial hoy se disputaron
los cuatro partidos de los grupos c y d
Francia ganó y se convirtió en el primer
equipo en pasar a los octavos mientras
que Argentina sigue viva en la fase de
grupos luego de su Victoria ante México
Colonia y Australia fueron los otros
vencedores de hoy desde doha nuestra
enviada especial Natalia Ruiz giraldo
nos hace un repaso de qué ocurrió en La
Jornada
Argentina juega el fénix Polonia pinchó
La burbuja de Arabia Saudita y Francia
logró su revancha Esos son los tres
resultados importantes de esta jornada
con Argentina que se midió aquí en el
estadio de los usail ante el actriz
ganando dos goles por Cero en un partido
bastante difícil con muchísimas
interrupciones hasta 16 faltas en tan
solo en la primera parte pero Argentina
que sale a flote gracias a dos
genialidades una de Leonel Messi y luego
la segunda de Enzo Fernández en todo
caso lo que ocurre con Argentina que por
ahora de segundo de grupo se va a decir
en el último partido en donde la albi
Celeste se enfrentará a Polonia Polonia
que a su vez ganó hoy a Arabia Saudita
dos goles por cero los saudíes que se
tuvieron que enfrentar ante el bromuro
de El Arquero polacochesni y dos goles
uno de celenski y el segundo de
lewandowski el 9 que por fin logra
marcar en la mundial por el lado de por
fin ganaron a Dinamarca dos goles por
uno doblete de mbappé e importante los
dos hombres que hicieron los pases para
estos goles el primero esteo Hernández y
el segundo es un griezmann y con este
resultado de dos goles por uno pues ya
Francia tiene seis puntos y es la
primera selección aquí en Qatar 2022 en
estar en octavos de final
ahora hablamos de la guerra en Ucrania
este sábado se restableció la
electricidad en jerson según la
presidencia ucraniana la luz la
calefacción y el agua estaban cortadas
en la ciudad desde el 11 de noviembre
cuando los ucranianos retomaron el poder
en la urbe ocupada por los rusos en el
resto del país seis millones de hogares
incluidos 600.000 es la capital Siguen
sin electricidad y los ataques de Rusia
a los sistemas energéticos continúan
una carrera contra el reloj mientras la
mitad de los habitantes todavía no
tienen electricidad el alcalde de la
ciudad acaba de expresar su gratitud a
los técnicos que restablecieron la
calefacción
quiero agradecerles a ustedes los 300
empleados de la compañía energética
templo de kiev ustedes quienes trabajan
día y noche gracias a ustedes podemos
anunciar hoy que el 97% de los hogares
tienen de nuevo calefacción las
temperaturas van bajando tener calor se
vuelve vital porque en Ucrania el
invierno está llegando y las
temperaturas han pasado bajo cero pero
Rusia sigue bombardeando las
infraestructuras civiles esenciales
dejando millones de ucranianos sin gas O
electricidad desde kiefa al norte hasta
odesal Sur desde las orillas del Bíper
al este hasta el VIP cerca de Polonia no
hago un llamamiento a todos por favor
hagan reservas de agua carguen sus
celulares piensen en las comunicaciones
Prepárense con sus familias en caso de
que caigan las conexiones
Esta es una foto del cielo ucraniano
tomada a principios de febrero por la
NASA y otra tomada este jueves
secundaciones unidas la falta de energía
en Ucrania este invierno podría llevar a
nuevos desplazamientos de la población
dentro de los cuales podría haber un
Éxodo afuera del país
en Irán en la yatula Ali llaménez le
rindió uno moneda bajé a la milicia
basic que ha reprimido las protestas que
llevan más de dos meses el líder supremo
dijo que ellos habían sacrificado sus
vidas a pesar de que los activistas
iraníes han denunciado la muerte de 448
personas en las manifestaciones mientras
que un equipo de médicos reportó que 140
iraníes perdieron sus ojos por el uso
del armamento de las fuerzas de
seguridad Gabriel coachet nos cuenta más
la represión general mientras las
manifestaciones entran en su tercer mes
en la provincia sudoriental desiste
andaluces están las fuerzas de seguridad
abrieron Fuego contra los manifestantes
el viernes según los activistas decenas
de personas murieron o fueron heridas
tras la jornada de protestas las
manifestaciones fueron convocadas en
todo el país esta semana en Solidaridad
con el kurdistán que junto con el System
baluchistán ha sufrido particularmente
de la mortífera respuesta de las fuerzas
de seguridad el sábado el líder supremo
de Irán alejarme saludó el trabajo de
los basics una milicia islámica que ha
tomado parte en la represión del
movimiento vieron en estos asuntos
recientes que el pueblo perseguido de
basic se sacrificó para evitar que la
nación sucumbiera a la fuerza de un
grupo de asesinos Rebeldes analfabetos
esclavos se sacrificaron para evitar la
crueldad de otros según la agencia de
noticias de activistas de Derechos
Humanos
448 personas fallecieron desde el inicio
de las protestas que fueron convocadas
tras la muerte de masa a mini las
autoridades iraníes por su parte afirman
que unos 50 efectivos de las fuerzas de
seguridad murieron en las movilizaciones
este jueves el consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU voto por la creación
de una investigación independiente sobre
la represión de las protestas pero eran
condenó la medida y dijo que era inútil
y representaba una violación de la
soberanía nacional del país
[Aplausos]
reapareció el ex presidente Pakistán por
primera vez desde que le dispararon hace
tres semanas y lo hizo con un mensaje
que profundiza la división política dijo
que su partido
abandonará todas las asambleas
regionales y nacionales recordemos que
este colectivo opositor fue el más
votado y ya había dejado la legislatura
lo que dejó en un limbo las elecciones
parlamentarias del jefe de estado
inracan también reiteró su exigencia de
hacer votaciones anticipadas bajo el
argumento de que él fue derrocado
ilegalmente pero el Primer Ministro
con la ayuda del gobierno estadounidense
desestima la acusación y se mantiene en
convocar las elecciones para el 2023
y terminamos con una triste noticia del
espectáculo murió Irene cara la actriz y
cantautora Quien ganó un Oscar y un
Grammy conocida por las películas flame
y Flashdance su publicista Judith
explicó a través de un comunicado en
Twitter que se le conoce la falla del la
causa del fallecimiento escuchemos la
canción del drama musical que le valió
un premio de la academia a la mejor
canción original y dos nominaciones a
los premios Grammy entre otros
reconocimientos
[Música]
y así despedimos las noticias de France
24 pero los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros
[Música]